[Musique]
hong kong
faisalabad et le hub textile du pakistan
la troisième plus grande ville du pays
compte 3 128 entreprises dans ce secteur
elle était autrefois surnommé le petit
manchester les vêtements des plus
grandes marques européennes et
américaines sont produits plusieurs
usines sont logés au coeur même des
zones résidentielles c'est le cas de
l'entreprise jubilee elle produit des
tissus imprimés vendus en gros sur le
marché local
voici les tissus bruts que nous achetons
sur le marché nous vérifions d'abord la
qualité nous vérifions qu'il n'y a pas
de défaut sur les vêtements ou de fil
qui dépasse
les employés travaillent sur ces
vieilles machines textiles sans aucune
protection
des données est là ce sont les machines
à laver pour nettoyer les vêtements pour
enlever toute la poussière
lisons quarante à cinquante mille litres
d'eau par heure et toute cette eau est
évacuée dans le système d'égout
principale de la ville sans être traiter
cette eau s'écoule directement dans le
sol il n'y a aucun traitement des eaux
usées ni aucun système de drainage le
manager sont des hommes mais il n'a pas
le choix dit-il
produire en respectant l'environnement
et très coûteux vous pouvez pas vous
lancer simple gouvernements coopèrent
avec vous est ici ne le fait pas donc si
vous décidez de le faire quand même vous
devez vous autofinancée et même si le
gouvernement accorde des prêts les taux
d'intérêt sont si élevés qu'ils sont
insoutenables
les cheminées des usines crachent leurs
fumées au milieu des habitations pour
les résidences et un calvaire au
quotidien
voyez ces usines sont juste à côté de
nos maisons elle dégage cette fumée
noire jour et nuit vous voyez ici les
cendres des usines et se déposent
partout ses cendres provoque des
maladies respiratoires de la tour des
maux de gorge et des complications
graves chez des enfants qui vivent dans
le voisinage samuel aran a récemment
développer de l'asthme et s'inquiète
pour ses enfants car les usines qui
fonctionnent au charbon pollue l'air
mais pas seulement
cette eau n'est pas potable elle sent
très mauvais nous ne pouvons même pas
prendre de douche avec
nous utilisons cette eau là pour boire
et nous brosser les dents
du robinet nous pouvons l'utiliser que
pour laver le linge ou faire le ménage
il existe pourtant des zones
industrielles à l'écart des zones
résidentielles comme celle d'allamma
iqbal situé à 30 km du centre ville
le groupe sadaqat à son usine ici il est
connu depuis 50 ans pour son âge de
maisons de qualité vendus sur le marché
local et international
le groupe stade à quat'sous traite pour
de grandes marques européennes il est
d'ailleurs parmi les 50 principaux
exportateurs du pays à 16 ans seulement
- man mortal et l'un des directeurs de
cette entreprise familiale l'une de ses
missions devenir plus écologique
nous avons réduit les déchets dangereux
de moitié et nous avons réutilisé
environ 1000 mètres cubes d'eau en 2019
ce n'est que le début
mon père mon père ce sont des hommes
d'affaires le fait est qu'il n'était pas
aussi informé que moi c'est donc à moi
de leur faire comprendre les enjeux
environnementaux nous la jeune
génération nous sommes plus conscients
du réchauffement climatique et la
nécessité
de prendre des initiatives
à l'extérieur d'ailleurs certaines
initiatives sont visibles
voici notre usine de recyclage de l'eau
nous sommes les seuls à en avoir une au
pakistan toute l'eau utilisée dans
l'usiné arrive ici pour être traité et
nous économisons comme ça environ 35 à
40% de l'eau que nous utilisons la
principale source d'énergie ici reste
pourtant le charbon le combustible le
plus polluant mais le groupe sadaqat se
donne dix ans pour devenir 100 %
écologique
la route est longue pour s'en rendre
compte il faut aller à lahore dans ce
marché les plus grandes marques du
prêt-à-porter occidental ses vêtements
étaient destinés à l'exportation mais
ils ont fini ici car ils ont été
produits en surplus ou parce qu'ils ont
de légers défauts de fabrication
avez-vous la marque de pantalons police
oui monsieur regardez ceci est un
pantalon de la marque police il a été
fabriqué à l'origine pour être exportées
en australie
il est de très bonne qualité et stretch
ici nous avons un jeans de springfield
son prix d'origine et de 50 euros
combien le vendez vous monsieur nous
vous proposons un prix très bas
seulement 1000 roupies
les marques produisent des vêtements en
grande quantité elle expédie les volumes
commandés le reste elle le jette ici le
coût environnemental de cette production
excessive est énorme le problème est
qu'il n'ya pas de lois au pakistan pour
empêcher cela il en profite
la pollution engendrée par l'industrie
textile est alarmante et s'ajoute aux
conséquences désastreuses du
réchauffement climatique déjà présente
dans le pays